the new trailer for Pet Sematary
suggests one major change from the novel
and one major change from the 1989 movie
if you haven't seen trailer number two
yet I'd recommend not watching it you
can just watch this things you miss
video and I'll tell you when to leave if
you want to avoid spoilers deal deal
let's roll that intro so the trailer
opens with the mother of the family
Rachel telling her husband that their
daughter Ellie discovered a charming
landmark in the woods and then it shows
Ellie wandering around the pet cemetery
by herself this is not how it goes down
in the book at all in the book their
neighbor jugs Randall takes the entire
Creed family to the pet cemetery to
introduce them to the woods behind their
house maybe that does still happen
because we do see both of them there
together later in the trailer and
trailers have been known to lie to us in
the past but when we do see Ellie
supposedly arriving at the pet cemetery
there's a little picture frame in the
bottom right corner with a photo of a
parrot when they first visit the pet
cemetery in the book Ellie's father
Louis notices a grave plot labeled
Polynesia and thinks to himself that
Polynesia would have been a parrot if he
remembers his dr. Doolittle correctly
and it would have squashed her last
Polly want a cracker in the summer of
1953 King also describes Polynesia's
grave when Lewis returns to the burial
ground towards the end of the book and
when he steps over the ragged chunk of
board that marks Polynesia's final
resting place it kind of represents him
going past the land of the dead also if
you go frame by frame while the
headstones are flashing on screen you
can read this one labeled Trixie killed
on the highway which is also one of the
grave markers that Louis reads when
first visiting the pet cemetery in the
book where he also sees the death date
September 15th 1968 so I think it's
pretty cool that they're referencing
some of the pet cemeteries animal
inhabitants in the movie nice little
Easter eggs one thing that's included in
the movie that's not in the book is this
mask left on one of the greys and these
kids wearing the masses they parade
their deceased pets to the cemetery
there is a story that Judd Crandall
passes down in the book about how the
kids would bring their pets down the
forest path to the cemetery sometimes
the pet owner would go alone like when
Judd buried his dogs spots and other
times they would have more of a funeral
procession type of thing I specifically
remember Judd telling of an argument
between two kids back in the day getting
into a debate about who got to hold on
to the caskets but the animal masks and
instruments were never a part of the
book
there are some things that are mentioned
in the book but after being absent from
the 80s film have returned for the new
adaptation let's roll the clip it's not
some campfire story so these are the
trees up there they're warnings the
local tribes carved and before they fled
Lewis researches the spiral in this book
called modern history of Eastern native
tribes the caption here says the
pictograph of the spiral was found
carved into the trees of the forests of
Maine as a warning to others or a way of
warding off the evil spirits
what is this evil spirit it's right
there the one to go and Algonquian
mythological creature in the case of pet
sematary it's referred to as a Micmac
legend the Wendigo has ties to
cannibalism and greed in times of famine
and resides in the northeast region of
the US some versions of the legends say
a human who craves another man's flesh
is cursed to become a Wendigo but the
one to go in Stephen King's novel is
more of a deity who stalks the ground of
low domain where the story takes place
Judd tells Lewis that the Mi'kmaq tribes
stopped using their burial ground
because the ground had been soured by
the one to go he also blames the one to
go for causing bad things to happen in
town telling Lewis he believes that the
Wendigo possessed him to show Lewis the
Micmac burial ground legend has it that
if the creature touches you it can turn
you into a cannibal
the picture shown in the trailer show
off the Wendigos cannibalistic side and
its form which matches the typical
depiction of the Wendigo with a human
body capped by the head or horns of a
stag the spiral is also mentioned in the
book but it's more of a sign of the
Wendigos intervention and an
introduction of ideas that go against
nature when Lewis visits Pleasant View
Cemetery he finds himself thinking about
the graves at the pet cemetery he refers
to the spiral is the oldest sign of
power in the world man's oldest symbol
of that twisty bridge that may exist
between the world and the goal Lewis
finds himself absent mindedly drawing a
spiral pattern in the dirt while he's
thinking and erases it before leaving
then later on when he returns to the
burial ground he notices that the rocks
have fallen in such a way to give the
appearance of a gigantic spiral giving
us the idea that a greater presence is
at work on one of the other pages of the
book someone is drawn in their own
spiral and a pentagram I'm guessing that
Lewis finds his hands drawing these
symbols without realizing it just as he
drew the spiral on the dirt in the book
judge Crandall is seen wearing a
throughout several scenes of the trailer
that says Lavetta motor oil this might
be an oil company based near Fort
LaVette in Maine which is named after
Christopher lebed's
one of the earliest settlers of the New
England area I think that Jud wearing
this hat means he represents the white
man laying down a path into Native
American territory that they have no
business meddling it Jud is the one to
show Lewis about how to get to the
Mi'kmaq burial ground and introduce him
to the power that it holds Native
American curses are a common theme in
Kings stories and speaking of Kings
writing it looks like there's a little
reference to carry with a hand reaching
out of the ground in grabbing Louis's
arm that's not something from the book
so I guess it's part of Louis's drain
one thing that was not shown in the
first trailer that has been revealed
here and the second one is a Zelda
Rachel's sister who passed away when
they were young from severe spinal
meningitis the thought of Zelda haunts
Rachel for the rest of her life and she
even has visions of her as an adult
which appears to be what's going on in
the scene and it looks pretty horrifying
we also get a better look at Louis's
encounter with Victor Pascal a
university student that dies under
Louis's care during his first day of
work and tries to warn him about the
evil that lies beyond the pet cemetery
in the book he was hit by a car while
out jogging it looks like they've
changed things up a bit in this new
movie because he's not wearing running
shorts and something is sticking out of
his neck can't really tell was I don't
know why this change was made and that
kind of leads me to my next points
however if you don't want any spoilers
this is the end of the line for you
remember to subscribe to see ZZZ world
for new Horrors every week bring the
death bell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one go watch this
video if you're still here you may have
already thought what I'm thinking that
Pascal's injury seems to just be changed
for changes say we won't know for sure
until we see the movie but as of right
now it certainly seems that way you've
probably also noticed that the trailer
seems to suggest that Ellie is gonna be
the one struck down by the truck as
opposed to her brother gage like I said
before trailers do lie sometimes but it
does seem like Ellie is seen running
into the road before the truck comes
there are le sais footprints on the
stairs and Ellie tracks mud into the
house and horrifies her mother with her
appearance and then as Rachael's
watching of her gauge something pops up
and scares her and it appears to be
Ellie at the end of the trailer a girl
with a cat mask attacks Judd which may
or may not be Ellie
but a lot of signs seem to point to her
being the one that Lewis has to bury in
the cursed burial ground so why was this
changed in the remake in my personal
opinion this would have been a fun
change if it had been for shock value
fans of the originals would go into the
movie expecting it to be gage who was
killed making it that much more shocking
when le is unexpectedly struck down but
now that they've gone and spoiled it in
the trailer that won't be the case at
all which just makes me think that this
is just another example of change for
the sake of change now maybe there is
some reason that the roles of le engage
are flipped in this film and I won't
make my final judgments until I have
seen the movie but if they are just
changing it for a reason then some of
the brilliance of the story is going to
be lost
for example the contrast between Louis's
first trip where he struggles to carry
gage in the baby backpack and his second
trip where he easily carries gages
corpse in the middle of the night is
gonna be lost because it's not like
he'll be carrying le during the first
trip in the movie and the psychological
trauma that gages death puts on le in
the book won't be there with gage in the
movie because he's just not old enough
to fully comprehend it like le would
have we will just have to wait to see
how everything shakes out but let me
know what you think of these changes so
far and make sure you subscribe to see
zis world and ring the death Bell so you
don't miss out on things you missed
episodes on the 1989 Pet Sematary its
sequel and more Pet Sematary related
content coming soon
to this channel I'll see you in the next
one assuming we both survived
[Music]